- [Voiceover] This is
the Blanding's turtle.
Look closely because they're
hard to spot in the wild.
Blanding's turtles aren't very big,
topping out at around
ten inches in length.
What distinguishes them is
their bright yellow chin
and throat.
Like the stereotype, Blanding's
turtles take their time.
However, once they've
reached full adulthood,
there is no slowing down.
A recent study found an 83 year old female
that was full of eggs ready to lay.
Their general habitat is
wetlands with shallow water.
Their range is centered
around the Great Lakes,
extending east to New York,
and up to southern Ontario.
But the wetlands they
call home are shrinking
and becoming fragmented
from human development,
the biggest threat to the
survival of this gentle
and timid creature.
This is the Blanding's turtle.
(chimes music)